you people make me sick
they make it their business to mind your
business
as if used condoms weren't enough to
sour commuters on public transit now a
new york city official wants to ban
backpacks or at least four strap hangers
to place them on the ground
which is often filthy
people are outraged over a proposed ban
on tobacco for the entire town outraged
residents at a public meeting in
westminster massachusetts made officials
rethink a proposal that would ban the
sale of all tobacco and nicotine
products i find smoking to be one of the
most disgusting habits anybody could
possibly do
on top of that i find this proposal to
be even more of a disgusting thing board
of health meeting was cut short by
protesters but the proposal is far from
dead westminster's three-person board
will render a decision in december but
this month we zero in on new york city
it's the scene of that catcalling video
that went viral as well as a debate
spurred by the new york times about
whether street harassment should be
against the law likening cat calling to
cross burning sociology professor laura
beth nielsen says the law should allow
women to sue those who verbally harass
them some missouri cities have laws that
can stick verbal harassers behind bars
kansas city is the most recent to adopt
such an ordinance which was passed in
order to encourage residents to walk and
bike more hollaback the organization
that made the viral video doesn't think
criminalization is the solution to
street harassment but only time will
tell if america's lawmakers agree
american eagle follow the show on
twitter submit your nanny nominees and
stay tuned later this month for nanny of
the year